okay so the vaping ban everyone's
talking about this I'm recording this
from my car right now because we have
the big livestream tonight 8 p.m.
Eastern the whole debates drinking game
costume contest follow me on Twitter so
I apologize that I'm not in the studio
it's being reset right now let me say
this for stuff i-i-i don't vape i you
know i do i have a friend who has a vape
and I'll grab a drag every now and then
didn't really don't really like the way
it makes me feel I do smoke cigars but
that doesn't matter yeah I think it's
very weird when people trying to look
through the lens of what affects them
with news stories for people who don't
know Donald Trump the FDA the White
House they're proposing an all-out
vaping ban on flavored East cigarettes
if you support that you're not a
conservative remember but if you are
against socialism if you are against
government intervention and you support
that you're not a principled person even
if you think even if you don't date and
by the way you can still still support
Donald Trump in most respects you can
still say that you think he's been a
pretty good president and acknowledge
that this is a horrible stupid policy
and precedent to set unless you're a
cheerleader right unless you're one of
those all right pom-pom waving trust the
plan of Donald Trump cheerleader this is
something that she really upset I notice
of this with a lot of people they are
against bans until it affects something
that that they care about that they want
banned so usually in the flip side right
you have liberals who are pro ban I'm
leftists probe and everything that they
think might be harmful until it comes to
their thing that might be banned you
know then there all of a sudden about
freedom right all of a sudden when it
comes to chopping up the baby and
sucking it down a tube we've crossed the
bridge too far
whereas in the flipside you have a lot
of conservatives and I mean a lot of
more so kind of the Trump cheerleaders
have come to it more newly by the way I
think even as a
prai's only good president so don't get
me wrong here but it's okay to question
dear later okay people need to
understand on the flip side you have
conservatives who are against bans until
it comes to banning something that they
find offensive sometimes that can be
pornography sometimes that can be
smoking in this case vaping vaping
they're trying to claim that vaping
markets the kids listen more kids are
probably vaping by the way what do you
think the over-under is on on Melania
having found Behrend with a jewel in the
bathroom I don't they I hate the I'm
kind of joking but I hate the idea that
that could be a cow at catalyst for
national policy something else I think
it's important is this ends up taking us
away from the science so listen I smoke
cigars and that's something coming down
the pike of people who don't know will
probably talk about it tonight
in the live stream again it's 8:00 p.m.
Eastern the whole democratic debates for
hours it's gonna be a big one the FDA is
also been looking at banning cigars
because it's not just a cigarette butt
all flavored cigarettes the idea is to
try and minimize underage tobacco use
which I understand I think that's a
that's a virtuous goal right to want to
cut down on underage use of tobacco well
they've decided to put cigars on this
let's hand rolled cigars by the way in
the same study I don't have it in front
of me this is on my phone here I think
it was the FDA said that most young
people are not smoking cigars
surprisingly enough because they're too
expensive and they're not flavored
hand-rolled cigars we're not talking
about blunts and swisher Sweets at the
local 7-eleven
do they sell cigars I have no idea I
know CVS doesn't anymore just you don't
need a fact check me on this but a
hand-rolled cigar
seven to ten dollars it's unflavored no
ingredient but pure unadulterated
tobacco these cigars come from
mom-and-pop companies they've been
passed down for generations and the FDA
might want to categorize that as all
other cigarettes and tobacco products
and by the way who does big tobacco that
favors the big companies that own say
your
and also happen to own the jewel and a
lot of the e-cigarette companies so a
couple of things here when we're talking
about the vaping ban for people out
there who may who may consider
themselves conservative and still
support the vaping ban all right let me
ask you this why why if you answer well
it's dangerous it's it's there have been
deaths from it no no there haven't now
there have been some lung related
illnesses and deaths from black market
black market cannabis cartridges that
had vitamin E oil and I think was if I'm
not mistaken vitamin E that acetate so I
want to make sure I'd be clear because
the pot crowds gonna get mad at me now
I'm not even saying cannabis vape not
CBD not even THC vape it was adulterated
contaminated cartridges with vitamin E
in there some derivative vitamin E that
becomes toxic when heated to the
temperature of vaporization how many how
many deaths with nicotine babe as soon
as someone doesn't vape none zero so
that's not a thing then we go into well
nicotine here's something else you know
I'm glad that in Colorado you can you
can smoke your 90% THC in your
hallucinogenic mushrooms but God forbid
somebody wants to go out for an
e-cigarette but even even looking at
that nicotine we've talked about this at
an ash wednesday we were comparing pot
versus nicotine and you know what you
should probably subscribe if you want to
watch it it requires a little bit more
explanation and nuance to use that word
than you can put here on YouTube but you
know what both of them have some
benefits and both of them have some
drawbacks there are medical benefits to
cannabis they're overhyped
there are some benefits that you hear
about that aren't valid at all and not
supported by the research but there are
some that are but a lot of people don't
know this nicotine once separated from
combustible cigarettes has a lot of
benefits to nicotine they're looking at
it as a very promising treatment for
Alzheimer's Parkinson's
neurodegenerative decline there was a
neuro scientists I think we covered this
on the website
who said that nicotine is the most
reliable cognitive enhancer that we know
of it enhances working memory it
enhances verbal fluidity it enhances
reaction time in most studies and
nicotine interestingly enough when
separated now if you don't smoke if you
don't use these cigarettes I'm not
saying go ahead and use nicotine but
nicotine when separated from combustible
cigarettes
especially nicotine in isolation when
you look at the animal studies is that
very addictive it's not very harmful
they do a test for rats you know that
you can self administer a drug by
pulling one lever or pulling basically
an active lever when it was nicotine by
itself about the other chemicals namely
there are some chemicals too and tobacco
that um act as sort of antidepressants
and extend the half-life of nicotine but
nicotine by itself is not that addictive
it is addictive so scaring so so's
marijuana by the way for people who
don't like to admit that but it's not
that addictive it's not that harmful and
as we see in Europe if people are able
to use e-cigarettes to get off of
traditional cigarettes which we know are
bad for you I see that as a good thing
and I also see it but right now I see
although this is a missed opportunity to
talk about the legitimate benefits or
potential medical uses of nicotine
because you know when I was an either
side of the fence with marijuana for a
long time - because people were pushing
it so hard as a cure for cancer and I go
it's bullcrap just don't talk to me I
don't even want to listen to you well
now I'm in the stage of my life and I've
talked about this where hey you know
what if there's a use to it and there's
a way to minimize any kind of harm for
example people taking mega doses and
smoking joints and driving but people
can reap the meta medicinal benefits
that's great we're not quite there with
nicotine but if there is a way to find
out how to isolate nicotine and if it
provides some kind of reliable cognitive
enhancement and potentially preventive
it could act as a preventative measure
for cognitive decline we should be
exploring that but all of this is to get
off the beam to say what do you agree
with anything that I've just said or not
whether you agree with the science and
the clinical trials Hertha's the studies
metadata or not you have to decide
should the government be banning things
just because you don't like that thing
should the government be in the business
of telling adults what they can and
cannot put in their own body provided
that it isn't harming other people and
if you answer yes to any of the above
and you have conservative or libertarian
in your Twitter profile you need to
remove it and if you say this is a great
thing just because Trump has done it you
have a problem you have a problem and I
would recommend seeking counseling or
having a cigar livestream tonight 8:00
p.m. Eastern the full Democratic debates
guests costume contest drinking rules to
follow